[Music]
whether you believe it to be the one
true money
or whether you think of it as nothing
more than an inert lump of metal
gold has been man's obsession for 6 000
years
i'm grant williams and in the first part
of our journey we explained the history
of gold
and how this strange yellow metal has
captured the hearts and minds of men
for thousands of years we showed you how
gold mining has evolved over the
centuries
and demonstrated the complexities of
refining and casting gold
and we took you underground for a never
before filmed look at the most secretive
gold vault in the world
we looked at the history of the gold
standard and saw how a president's
decision to close the gold window in
1971
profoundly changed the world around us
and perhaps most importantly
we showed you why gold became and
remains money
in the second part of our journey we'll
look at the difference between eastern
and western attitudes towards gold
we'll explain the difference between
gold etfs and the physical metal
and why that makes the gold price
different to the price of gold
we'll ask the all-important question is
the gold price manipulated and
if so by whom finally we'll talk about
the possible future of gold
what role if any could cryptocurrencies
play and is bitcoin the new gold
or just another doomed alternative to
the only money that stood the test of
time
[Music]
while it's been used as money and a
store of value for thousands of years
man's relationship with gold goes much
much deeper
and its place in history extends far
beyond coins bars and jewelry
we begin the second and final
installment of our journey
with a look at some of the properties of
this remarkable yellow metal
gold's durability means that just about
every ounce ever mined is still above
ground today
refined and recast many times over a
ring bought today in a souk in dubai
may contain traces of gold that once
graced the neck of cleopatra
that's just one of the many interesting
facts about gold
gold is among the rarest of the elements
making up only three parts per billion
of the earth's crust
if you want to know how hard that makes
gold to find picture a billion m
ms and somewhere in amongst that pile
there are just three
made of gold gold weighs 19 times more
than water
and is twice as heavy as lead over 90
of the world's existing above ground
gold has been mined since the california
gold rush
and if all the existing gold in the
world was pulled into a wire five
microns thick
it could wrap around the world 11.2
million times
throughout history man has mined 188 000
tons of gold
to put that into perspective you could
place all of it into two olympic sized
swimming pools
[Music]
but it's not just bars in a vault or
rings on fingers gold has many other
uses
in fact aside from its monetary and
symbolic value gold is widely used in
electronics
and electrical wiring dentistry medicine
radiation shielding and to color glass
in fact more gold can be recovered from
a ton of computers
than from 17 tons of gold ore
even the human body contains about 0.2
milligrams of gold which is found mostly
in our blood
by far the largest above-ground stock of
gold resides in the secure vaults of the
world's central banks
in total the top 10 central banks in the
world own some 23 000 tons of gold
and the imf owns another 2 000 tonnes
this equates to around 12 percent of all
the gold
ever mined
throughout thousands of years of history
gold's remarkable elemental properties
have provided an incredibly stable store
of value but those same properties
have led many critics to look upon it as
a boring asset which they claim
in the long term offers low returns at
best
this viewpoint however completely misses
the point of gold's place in a portfolio
because
perhaps counter-intuitively boredom is
actually one of its most attractive
qualities
well critics argue that it provides
boring returns because they're thinking
of gold as an investment
gold doesn't provide shouldn't provide
any return and it's not an investment
the reason gold doesn't provide any
return is because it doesn't have any
risk
and there's no return without risk so a
hundred dollar bill doesn't provide any
return unless you deposit it in the bank
at which point it's no longer a hundred
dollar bill it's a liability of the bank
and you are the creditor with the risk
of the bank not paying you back
and the biggest risk that it doesn't
have which all financial assets have in
trump's
and that is uh the risk of permanent
impairment
in other words the risk of permanent
loss of value
gold price can go up it can go down but
gold itself
is permanent gold is a is an excellent
hedge in times of rising inflation
while in deflation
it works pretty well but you shouldn't
focus on prices then then you should
really focus on
uh on the purchasing power because if
gold goes down 10
and stock prices go down 70 percent
it's still pretty good i would say
because you're just increasing you're
massively increasing your purchasing
power
if you think about the set of
circumstances that allows gold to do
well
they're always not always but they're
often catastrophic circumstances
so i would agree with you gold offers
boring returns
boring returns like 35 in 1971
and what twelve hundred and fifty
dollars today if you think about the
returns of other asset classes that
don't offer up insurance
give me that boredom
to many people gold is simply a price on
a tv screen or a computer terminal
and it's often nothing more than the
fluctuations in this price in both
directions
which are used to determine whether
owning gold has been a successful
investment or not
but is this fixation on its price the
correct way to think about gold
and if not then what is people focus on
the price of gold but also people focus
on the price of everything
this is a product of financialization
people know the price of everything in
the value of nothing
financialization has ushered a period
where markets
uh price everything and so people can
track prices of everything and the value
they're worth
by the amount of dollar units that they
that they have
people who are very focused on the
amount of money they have
should move to japan because they would
have a hundred times more money
because japanese yen is a hundred to one
dollar so if you want to be a
millionaire
you can do it a lot faster there then
you can do it here yes a lot of people
uh invest in gold they get very upset
because gold goes up or down in price
and they think they bought the wrong
time or they sold the wrong time
of course this is the wrong way to think
about it because the reason goals and
money for
thousands of years is because it's the
most stable element and what's really
happening of course is the dollar is
going up and down
in terms of gold not vice versa and it
is true uh that you can make it lost
some money in speculations
fiat currencies do go up in value
occasionally in fact even in the middle
of the weimar hyperinflation
uh the mark would have sudden huge
surges higher
and people who'd leveled themselves up
in gold and basically short of the mark
who get
cleaned out and this happens today in
the gold market too so
so people really shouldn't focus on the
gold price they should focus on
preserving their capital
and gold does that gold preserves your
purchasing power in fact
gold increases your purchasing power
over time and and uh it's best not to
get too cute
uh when you're in a a sinking ship which
is what the us dollar is right now
i think unless you really understand the
structure of the global gold market
it's a little bit of a fool's errand to
focus solely on the what the price of
gold is
so for example since 2013 in particular
early 2013 we've seen significant
flows physical flows out of the west
going broadly defined east china
in particular and those physical flows
have not
driven they actually have driven a
decline in the price
and since late 2013 the price has
effectively gone nowhere even as
physical flows have moved
and so when i say if you focus solely on
the price
i think you're you're you lose a lot of
informational
value or the the full mosaic of what's
actually happening
most people will fixate on the gold
price there's a very distinct difference
between the gold price and the price of
gold
the price of gold refers to the cost of
putting a coin or a bar in your hand it
represents
the cost of the physical metal itself
meanwhile the gold price
has become nothing more than a reference
point a number by which any number of
paper gold products
are priced on a daily basis all around
the world
but what do we mean by paper gold and
why is the astonishing rise of these
derivative contracts
potentially very very dangerous
these are contracts i say paper it's
really a contractual relation it takes
many forms
that give you exposure to the price of
gold but don't give you actual
gold and there are many of them so what
are they a gold future on the comex the
commodity exchange part of the chicago
american deal exchange show
a comex gold future would be paper gold
a gold etf a gld is the leading one
gld okay so the etf for example i'm not
buying gold
a lot of people think they are i'm
buying a share of a
stock that's traded on new york stock
exchange that share of stock entitles me
to
basically price exposure when i sell it
i'm not selling it back to the vault
i'm selling it to somebody else who
wants to buy it paper gold
represents gold that is
circulated in certificated form so one
example of paper gold
might be gld the uh etf
uh which is a derivative really of gold
the trades on the new york stock
exchange it's efficient for holders
because you don't have to go down to a
bullion shop
pick it up expose yourself to being mug
being mugged and buried in the backyard
it doesn't however represent physical
gold and for people who are nervous
about the financial system
the fact that they own a derivative when
what they really want
is payment in fist is very difficult for
them
paper gold is basically the futures
market i would say
um there's huge volume in the in the
future of
futures markets and my perspective has
always been um
if you want to buy gold um
for safety reasons um to to to to hedge
against uh
financial disaster or whatever you have
to buy physical gold
you don't want to have any counterparty
you have to have the real thing
if you want to speculate with it of
course you can buy
paper gold but it's just not the real
thing
the difference between owning a paper
contract or claim on gold versus holding
the metal itself
while seemingly trivial is a hugely
significant one
the idea of owning a paper claim on
physical gold however
is viewed very differently in the west
than it is in the east
after countless episodes of inflation
and where the debasement of fiat
currencies by governments is commonplace
gold is viewed very differently indeed
there is a deeper cultural familiarity
with gold
when i give the sort of gold lecture as
an example to young south asian women
they laugh at me they say in our culture
we have 1500 years
experience with gold we have known for a
much longer time
than you that the government is not our
friend
that we need a medium of exchange that's
simultaneously a store of value
my suspicion is that any culture that
has
less rather than more social trust has a
greater affinity for gold
because gold traditionally has been
something that obviated the need for
trust
the west did have for
a hundred years or or so or longer a
very credible governments limited
government eastern governments have not
had such a happy
history of limited government allowing
the people to
to the freedom the liberty to hold money
as they see fit and therefore
eastern populations tend to trust their
governments less and sensibly so
and so i think that the the idea that
gold is money
uh uh never faded in the east that we
did in the west because no one ever
trusted
uh fiat fiat currency from from those
governments uh so
it's a lesson that we relearned in the
west um i i think fairly shortly but
uh but i think that that is an important
distinction it's not blanket
sort of east versus west on this one
because i would say that [ __ ]
there's a there's definitely a sort of
distinction there between um
what i would call traditionally stable
countries and traditionally
unstable countries because you know i
think in singapore for instance or hong
kong
yeah the older generations you know they
they still think of gold as the ultimate
form of money it's a sort of safe haven
yeah um but the young don't right
so they they trust their government's
money that is less
true um in some of the poorer poorer
countries
the old have never trusted their
currency uh in uh um
in indonesia for instance or india
they've been right not to
by the way and um and the young don't
much either that weirdly has served them
extraordinarily well
relative to the developed world i think
the
difference between the way the gold is
viewed in the east
versus the way gold is viewed in the
west
is is probably at its core
a function of history i think it's been
for people in the west and people in the
u.s in particular
it's been a very long time since the u.s
has had
a problem with its currency a problem
with sovereign insolvency
it's a part of that's a function of uh
you know this exorbitant privilege we've
had since since the
the gold window was closed in 1971.
whereas
people in the east have had much more
recent familiar personal
experience uh with with
currency problems with currency
depreciation and there's a greater
degree of skepticism in the east
and like i said more importantly a
greater degree of real experience in
having these currency depreciation from
which gold protected them
you know i think the other reality is in
the west
and i think it's a real credit to policy
makers in the west
financiers in the west there have been
particularly again
in the u.s much
there's a much greater degree of ability
to manage
financial asset prices um you know the
creation there's a there's a great
declassified us document from 1974 from
the u.s embassy in london saying
you know the creation of a large a very
large paper gold futures market would go
a long way in managing the price of gold
because
and it would therefore reduce american
demand for physical gold
and you know that would be a good thing
um
it's right there black and white you can
see it it's official u.s history
uh i just attended a conference in
singapore and people don't care about
prices they constantly accumulate gold
they regard it
as as as a currency as money
they don't really care about the prices
yeah they just want to own
gold lots of gold while in the west i
think
um we tend to buy very pro cyclical
um normally if if you follow
etf demand for example etf demand always
goes up when prices go up yeah
so i think it's more momentum driven
on the other hand if i compare the
attitude regarding gold for example
in in austria where i come from or in
germany i think in our
sort of monetary dna there's still the
hyperinflation because our grandparents
they basically
they lost everything while people in the
united states
they're still kind of traumatized from
from the great depression and from
deflation and i think this also kind of
explains why our central banks are
acting very very differently the chinese
in the in
in this century have been buying gold
they've actually had nothing
12 years ago and today
they have bought more than or as much as
the annual production of gold
every year and then now nobody knows how
much the chinese have but they probably
have
20 000 tons of gold whatever whatever
the split is between central and private
we don't know but they certainly have
now more gold than anybody else
since the first gold futures contract
was launched in 1972
there's been a strong move towards paper
gold in the west
futures contracts and latterly an
explosion of etfs have meant there are
now any number of ways to own a paper
claim of sorts
on the ultimate physical asset without
actual ownership
however this idea of owning paper gold
isn't restricted to individual investors
over the years even central banks in the
west have traded in their physical gold
for paper contracts or promises
this time in the form of leasing
agreements to the so-called bullion
banks
but why do western investors prefer etfs
over physical gold and how could that
preference potentially come back to bite
them
well people prefer tfs for not just for
gold i mean
we see a massive shift from active
management to passive management
and i think one of the reasons for that
is during the in the stage of
financialization
you know larger companies larger
capitalization companies are
on average are doing better than small
companies because of economies of scale
and because of
cheaper borrowing costs and so forth
which is again is anti-competitive
product of financialization product of
the type of system that we now
credit-based system that we now have
um oligarchical system that we now have
and so in that type of environment you
know etf
are easy they're cheap
and they are equities
and if you think about gold specifically
you have to think of the structural
nature of the asset management industry
where most managers have all the
managers have what's called a mandate
which is they have a policy that says
what they can buy and what they cannot
buy
almost all managers have a mandate to
buy equities
very few managers have the mandate to
buy commodities
particularly physical commodities and so
to buy physical commodity there has to
be a whole process of
uh approving it through committees and
so forth whereas
they can buy you know an etf which is
just a stock
uh any minute of the day and they don't
have any issues with that
etfs solve a problem that just just
doesn't exist i mean you know they they
they they bill it as a kind of oh it's
so easy you can trade with it through
your
your uh charles schwab account or
something like that
oh yeah fair enough but you know charles
schwab could easily trade
if they if they if they if they weren't
getting a
sort of kickback of some form or other
they must be in some way shape or form
um from the etf providers um
they could easily they could easily have
us as a counterparty and we could we
could trade physical gold and instead of
having an etf
and you know essentially an equity with
an underlying relationship with god they
could have
physical gold right and that's not
difficult to do
you know it's just it's just a function
of looking up on the internet
spending five minutes on google and
finding a firm like us
filling out a few forms and you know
perhaps your father's brother kind of
thing
it's not it's not difficult at all if
you're on goal to speculate on the price
then of course etf is probably fine if
you
if you want to own gold as a insurance
or as an insurance or as a hedge uh and
i don't mean financial hedge i mean a
real hedge protection
against uh monetary disorder against
a financial system then of course owning
it
inside financial system doesn't make any
sense so let's say in the case of gld i
don't
know what it is today but it's ranges in
the 10
range or so so that means that for every
100 shares of gld there's actually 110
shares
out there outstanding 10 of which being
borrowed and sold short
so there are more shares than there are
actual
real shares and i think that's a pro
that's not a problem in the normal
market but that's a problem precisely in
the type of a situation
when you need your gold as insurance so
all of these types of risks
that etfs bring which are 100
correlated to the misfortunes potential
misfortunes of capital markets
uh financial institutions and monetary
system
are precisely why you own gold so why
would you want to commingle the two why
would you take the risks
that you're not going to get paid when
the time to get paid
comes because of its fascination for
mankind
gold has always been surrounded by
conspiracy theories and stories of price
suppression and manipulation
that's really no surprise after all
wherever you find money
you inevitably find human beings trying
to cheat in some way or another
fake gold bars have frequently surfaced
over the years with gold-plated tungsten
which has an identical density to gold
being the most common substitute
fortunately any one of a number of very
simple tests
will provide a conclusive answer as to
whether a particular bar is fake or not
gold is unique however the most
important questions about possible
manipulation of the gold price
concern much broader issues and occur at
a much
higher level well the question about
manipulation is is
clearly um a favored one people like to
discuss this
i i do think that um
[Music]
even a cursory glance at historical fact
will lead you in a fairly clear
direction i mean
it it's not like this is a hidden thing
i mean the london gold pool
existed it was an overt way of managing
the gold price
in terms of its of its um price
uh it's clearly in the interest of
central bank to manage
particularly in in the monetary system
as it functions right now whether it
does function not being a slightly
separate point it's clearly in in their
interest
to to manage the risk-free rates
would you influence the gold price well
it said the gold is the reciprocal trust
in central banks
you betcha um with a cheaper gold price
notwithstanding the fact that central
banks
are the biggest holders of gold 60
percent of their reserves are in gold
would you want to suppress it you betcha
the problem's too big are they doing it
i don't know is the answer
but money there's almost a racing
certainty they probably are
others however are far more confident
not only as to the question of whether
the gold price is manipulated but also
who the culprits might be
well the gold price is absolutely
manipulated when i say that i'm not
you know implying some deep dark
conspiracy i don't think janet yellen
wakes up in the morning and thinks about
gold i don't think johnny yellen knows
anything about gold to be honest i mean
she's sort of a
geeky liberal labor economist who
worships the phillips curve so i don't
think janet yellen is behind some
conspiracy to
you know suppress the price of gold but
there's absolutely manipulation and i've
spoken to uh
several experts one is a phd
statistician so
it's not a phd in economics it's phd in
statistics works for one of the largest
hedge funds in the world
he looked at a 10 year time series and
he took
like literally tick by tick information
on the comex gold future for 10 years
and he said there is no explanation for
this data other than manipulation it
could not possibly have happened through
normal market forces
in particular he noticed that at the end
of the day like on the last trading tick
uh on the comex the price of gold got
smacked down
and then at the open the next day it
could kind of pop up again
so he said well this is the easiest
trade in the world just buy gold right
after the close
and sell it the next morning you know
just before the open and you'll just
make consistent steady profits well
anyone knows anything about about
markets and uh
how they operate knows that you cannot
make consistent steady profit this is
what bernie madoff said he was doing
right
so he said the probability that the
price naturally goes down
at the close and naturally goes up the
next point is zero after 10 years
and this is not inference i mean this is
like dna
like you know you may not see the crime
being committed but if you have the dna
evidence you can be pretty sure who did
it
governments everywhere throughout
history
have wanted to manage it it's a critical
national security you know whether you
go back to the time of the romans etc
value of a currency is very very
important to manage particularly
if uh you're a government that hasn't
managed your
finances all that well um and
unfortunately that is over time most
governments sooner or later find
themselves in that position and so
the manipulation is right there in the
open and that it
it is a creation of a of a derivative
market
that satisfies demand that would
otherwise go to physical and that
that was the goal of setting that up and
that's not well understood i don't think
by many market participants but
as i said it's there in black and white
in the historical archives
when you see gold trade the way it
trades when it drops
you know someone sells three billion
dollars worth of you know notional
futures at
2am new york time um you know having
been on wall street for 22 years
i know for a fact that if any buy-side
trader would execute an order like that
on any consistent basis
they'd be out of a job very very quickly
you know they're they're clearly
somebody
not trying to get best you know best
execution and
and if they're not trying to get best
execution what you're talking about the
currency intervention
basically uh and so you know who is
doing that is that
originally the us government had a very
strong interest in
managing uh the person either the
perception of the dollar through gold
yeah there was a you know famously in
the late 1990s eddie george
an official with the i believe with the
bank of england in uk
he famously said we looked into the
abyss you know if the gold price
continued to rise
it would take it would have taken down
one major trading house and and a number
of others would have followed and so
there was a
you know there is a sign there that the
banks at that point had gotten
involved in you know gold financing that
have left them short gold
in a way that any real rise in gold
would have you know
you know led to an existential threat to
to them yes i think the price of gold is
manipulated
and i think it's manipulated in a number
of ways i mean certainly there is a
a concerted pr campaign against gold by
central banks
for the reasons that that we've
discussed you know they they
it is very specifically in the status
and central banker
kind of interest to ensure a a weak gold
price you don't want to see
essentially the gold uh price de facto
recreating a sort of reserve
currency by by just being incredibly
strong
so there's a there's a constant barrage
of negative publicity towards the gold
uh the gold industry when it comes to
specific manipulation of the gold price
yeah i think that that is
is probably likely to i mean i can't the
problem is we can't actually tell
because of the way central banks
don't um you know are very very opaque
with what they do with their gold
holdings and particularly their gold
swap positions but i think it's likely
and the reason why i think it's likely
is because they've been manipulating
other markets for a very long period of
time
now historically hedge funds were not
players in gold there was a few
specialists but
you know they're doing stocks bonds
whatever well they've sort of glommed
onto gold to them it's just another
commodity it could be coffee beans
soybeans
lumber who cares it's a thing to trade
well
if you're if you're short gold like
you've
done some derivative contract with
goldman sachs in your short it's easy to
paint the tape i mean painting the tape
just means
manipulating the market through the gold
futures market now the other day well
recently a few weeks ago somebody sold
60 tons equivalent of paper gold now i i
make the point they didn't sell 60 tons
of gold they sold
gold futures contracts that were
equivalent to 60 tons but i can sell 60
tons of paper gold
with a phone call to my broker all i
need is a brokerage account they gotta
put some margin like five percent
uh but that it drove the price down i
forget i think
twenty thirty dollars an ounce in in a
matter of minutes
um and so uh if i'm short over here on
the derivative side
and i dump the gold here and the price
goes down
and then all of a sudden i make money
over here or
maybe i want to go long and i want to
dry the price down and then
buy at the bottom and ride it back up
again so
perhaps unsurprisingly hedge funds and
bullying bank traders push the gold
price around to try and make profits
but while gold remains a strategic asset
which sits at the foundation
of many nations balance sheets there are
players far
far bigger than hedge funds who don't
care about making a profit
but who have much broader and far
stronger motivation to suppress the
price of bullion
the the important question is who's
doing it and why
um there are and the question i ask is
why is it not being investigated by the
regulatory authorities by the
commodity futures trading commission et
cetera now one possible answer to that
is that the chinese are behind it and
they're outside the jurisdiction there's
no way
that a u.s government agency is going to
investigate the activities of china in
our markets china's too big
their sovereign nation that would not go
anywhere
um there could be a million diplomatic
and
national security and other reasons for
not messing with china in that dimension
so china's my number one suspect because
people go wait a second they got all
this gold why would they want the price
to go down well the answer is they're
still buying
ultimately they're going to want the
price to go where it's going to go which
is ten thousand dollars an ounce or
higher
but they don't want that now because
they're still buying
they're playing catch up with the united
states and by the way they've bought
thousands of tons which is a lot of gold
but they have thousands of tons to go to
equal the us in the golden gdp ratio
we're either in the absolute sense to
get to 8
000 tons or in the proportional sense
gold to gdp
either way they're still playing catch
up with the united states
but not every gold market veteran buys
into the idea that the gold price is
subject to manipulation
it has to be said some of the reasons
they offer as to why the idea of a
state-sponsored price suppression scheme
may be far-fetched
are both simple to understand and hard
to argue with
i think that all financial markets are
manipulated from time to time
unlike many of my peers in the gold
business i have seen
upwards price manipulation when that is
easier
long-term manipulation requires a
conspiracy of a size
that i don't think is possible the idea
is an example that the u.s
government the trilateral commission and
the international jewish conspiracy
whoever they are could come together and
do a
decade long manipulation in gold forgets
that the u.s government can't educate
the kids it can't deliver the mail
it lost the war on drugs it lost the war
in poverty it lost the war in vietnam
and
lost the war in afghanistan how on earth
could they
organize a broad scale manipulation
when they can't even manage their own
campaigns
most governments eventually wind up
manipulating the gold price to protect
their own power
so certainly a possibility i i've never
seen any hard evidence of that
and also i would say that it is the
nature of gold
to underperform other assets in a credit
bubble you don't need
a nefarious federal reserve uh pushing
it down because that's what happens
naturally incredible everything
else goes up in terms of gold and of
course when the bubble ends
it must uh things crash in terms of gold
that is a natural
thing and it's really what we saw over
the last 40 years when
i mean for example from 2000 to 2008
bill went up in nominal prices
it went down in terms of oil and other
commodities so in fact it
did very badly uh in real terms
uh when when the bubble had popped in
2008 and nine
gold did fantastically well in nominal
and real terms and then bernanke
managed to uh blow a bigger bubble and
so it's no really surprise
that gold did badly during that period
now it was with the fed manipulate
downwards
i mean it's possible but we don't need
that as a theory
but why would any suppression of the
gold price be so important
and what might happen were it to be both
exposed and shut down
in january 2018 a group of traders
working for the big bullion banks became
the latest market participants
to be fined for trying to manipulate
precious metals markets
a patent that has been commonplace over
the years
but this proof of price manipulation in
the gold market like many similar
episodes which have gone before it
had no meaningful impact on the price
however any manipulation in the gold
market like all price suppression
schemes
will ultimately come to an end at some
point and when it does
the potential ramifications are enormous
all manipulations fail at the end of the
day they all fail
the 1968 london gold pool failed late
1970s u.s and imf dumped uh
sorry 1700 tons of gold in the market it
failed the price in 1980 was higher than
ever
uh late 90s we twisted uh the uk's arm
got them to sell
over half their gold um now they're
stuck uh early 2000's it was
switzerland's town we got them to sell
about 2 000 tons but the problem is we
have now run out of suckers
to sell the gold in one day
the holders of paper gold will realize
that they will never get delivery
because there ain't any gold to deliver
against it
and they will sit there with a piece of
paper and whether it's comex or the
bullion banks would
uh you know all the people dealing with
they will default
and at that time there just won't be any
gold available and the gold price will
obviously shoot straight up and it would
be very hard to buy gold
one of the core lessons of history is
that the market is more powerful than
governments
and when this bubble we're living it
currently pops it doesn't matter how
much they try to manipulate it
gold will not be manipulated to that
extent so it will break out whether
they're manipulated
now or not alongside conspiracy theories
and stories of manipulation gold's
history is
filled with wonderful illustrations of
how much it means to mankind
the extraordinary importance placed on
protecting it and the sometimes deadly
lengths
people will go to in order to possess it
in september 1939 as the german army
advanced towards britain
the government decreed that every person
living in the united kingdom
registered their gold with the royal
treasury just
weeks later on the 7th of october 1939
hms emerald set sail from plymouth in
great britain
for halifax nova scotia the reason the
hull contained millions of pounds of
gold bullion
bound for the usa to pay for american
war materials
twelve months later with the war going
badly for the allies and the battle for
the north atlantic at its fiercest
prime minister winston churchill used
emergency wartime powers
to seize the gold the citizens of the uk
had been forced to declare the previous
year
the gold was moved to the port of
greenwich in scotland in secret
reloaded onto hms emerald and then
dispatched to canada
so if the british were to be overrun by
the advancing nazi forces
they would still have the means to
continue the fight one week later
another convoy set off on the same route
this time carrying 1.7 billion dollars
of gold
today that goal will be worth over 29
billion dollars
in all almost 30 billion dollars of gold
in today's money were shipped thousands
of miles
in treacherous seas and through a
gauntlet of u-boats without a single
ounce being lost
it was the single greatest and perhaps
most dangerous movement of wealth
in history stories such as the daring
evacuation of britain's gold during
world war
ii are well documented but alongside
such historical tales
there are legends surrounding missing
hordes of gold that have fascinated
treasure hunters since time began
one such legend centers around a
notorious japanese general
and a hidden gold stash which today will
be worth billions
the legend of yamashita's gold has
endured for over 70 years
and to this day attracts treasure
hunters from all over the world who
journey to the philippines
to search for billions of dollars
supposedly looted from all over
southeast asia
by general tomiyuki yamashita the
notorious tiger of malaya
yamashita's army stole gold from bank
vaults depositories and commercial
premises as he cut a swathe through asia
with the japanese government intent on
using their ill-gotten gains
to finance their expanding war effort
the gold reached the philippines
on its way to singapore from where it
was to be shipped to japan but with the
war in the pacific escalating and the us
navy and the ascendant
it became impossible to move the goal
instead it was supposedly hidden
somewhere deep in the philippine jungle
many of those who knew the location of
the hidden treasure
were killed during the war and yamashita
himself was executed for war crimes in
february of 1946
without giving up the whereabouts of the
eponymous stash
in the intervening 70 years hundreds of
fortune hunters have sought yamashita's
gold
a treasure hunter named rogelio roxas
filed a lawsuit in hawaii against former
philippine president ferdinand marcos
who he accused of stealing the gold
but even that has failed to stop
adventurers applying to the national
museum of the philippines for a treasure
hunter's permit
roxas lawsuit resulted in what was then
the largest ever award made by a court
40.5 billion dollars including damages
however the amount was reduced on appeal
to just 13 million dollars
roxas however died mysteriously on the
eve of the trial
and so never saw his treasure hunt come
to its conclusion
the lawsuit concluded that roxas found a
treasure but that the treasure in
question
may not have been that of yamashita the
technicality
which has been enough to maintain a
steady stream of would-be indiana
joneses
heading for manila the colorful history
which plays such a big part in mankind's
attachment to gold
stands in stark contrast to the
situation facing us in the present
as the world's ever-increasing reliance
on debt to sustain a creaking monetary
system
threatens to bring the financial world
as we know it to its knees
in episode one we looked at how the gold
standard worked and more importantly
perhaps
how it was ended by richard nixon on
august the 15th 1971
but is a return to the gold standard a
possibility and if so
what would a reimposition of financial
discipline mean for the modern day
monetary system
why is this a source of contention for
so many people
it's a source of contention for people
who like debt
in other words governments
banks people who like to live beyond
their means
so for them it's a source of contention
because gold
makes it impossible to borrow more than
you can afford
to repay whereas with fiat money
you can essentially borrow without limit
and then print the money
to pay it back so it's bad for people
who make
money from producing additional money
like banks fractional reserve banking
bad for central banks bad for
governments who like to wage wars and
pay for them with
you know tickets that they print in
unlimited quantities but i think it's
good for everybody else it's good for
savers it's good for people who
want to know that they can save money
for retirement and that money be worth
the purchasing power have the purchasing
power that it had when they were setting
it aside having some sort of gold
standard
is is very it
you would have a lot of antipathy
towards that because that prevents you
from
fighting a war anytime you want it
prevents you from promising you know
medicare part d anytime you want it
you know all of these things that
um you know keep you in washington or
keep you
really in any country for that matter
but in in particular given how the
currency system has developed
over the last 30 40 years um you know
it's only the u.s that has exorbitant
privilege there's
the way the system is structured there
are other governors or breaks that exist
for other countries that have not
existed
uh for the united states uh for a long
time and i think that that ultimately is
why
there's such a high degree of um
establishment
you know antipathy towards towards uh
towards the gold standard
interestingly when central bankers
talked with the gold standard they seem
to be vaguely aware of his benefits
what they say is that its costs are too
high and what are those costs
the costs are that the fed and the
government can't manipulate the economy
the idea is that
under the gold standard uh you'd have
terrible depressions and
employment would be you know very very
high levels and there's nothing
government could do but and that cost
too high because
the government can now stabilize prices
and of course this is absolutely crazy
because
what created the bubbles in the 19th
century in the early 20th century were
not was not the gulf standard it was the
banking system it was a flawed
bank the fraction fractional bank system
by its nature blows bubbles and
collapses not gonna do with gold
whatsoever in fact
as we've seen when they switch the world
from a goal center to a dollar standard
we still get bubbles and
they're worse than ever were so it's the
stabilization that makes the problems in
fact
during the great depression in the 1930s
hayek
wrote that it was the stabilizers in the
20s that created the problems that they
didn't let the market clear they
tried to keep prices too high so i it
wasn't it wasn't the gold that did it
the gold standard that did it it was the
bank system that made all these bubbles
but
uh it so it's it's beyond bizarre to see
ben bernanke get up and blame gold for
all the problems that
the bank system he was managing and now
yellow manages
is responsible for all these problems i
don't think sufficient gold in the world
in our current position to be able to
support it not without a readjustment in
the gold price i think someone came up
with a figure of 35 000
an ounce um
the argument clearly for it would be
that it would force upon
the regulators the official institute
the central bankers in particular
discipline in terms of qe i suspect that
there will be some
moment in time uh rebalancing i think
they're using the word reset
nice soft word personal word like reset
that will occur
in the next short few years and that
something new will evolve and it might
involve
linking gold partly to gold or something
else
i think that there'll be a lot of
pressure on central banks to create a
new currency that is linked to something
that can't be queued
and created out of thin air you can't
print this stuff
once called a barbarous relic by john
maynard keynes
gold is the oldest continuous medium of
exchange known to man
so what a reset of some sort seagull
continue to hold its position
and remain the cornerstone of the modern
financial system
in recent years the emergence of
cryptocurrencies such as bitcoin
has ignited furious debate about gold's
future in the monetary system with many
believing that crypto currencies
finally obviate the need for gold the
most likely future however
is not a case of when it takes all do i
think that there's room
as a medium of exchange for an algorithm
that also obviates the need for trust
is seamless and private like bitcoin
absolutely do i want
all of my savings stored
in a unit of value whose only value is
an algorithm
no i as a consumer of currency
want lots of currencies and i want to
pick and choose the utility at different
points in time in my career
for different purposes with regards to
my life and my family's life
bitcoin and gold other competing faith
systems
the nice thing about cryptocurrencies is
that nobody owns in the sense that it's
a
democratic arrangement through the
distributed ledger we all own the
ownership of
the bloc and you can then buy parts of
it bits or
touch the chain in other words you can't
qe it
it has a discipline inherently built
into the system
the problem is it's not to use it's not
a medium exchange
and quite probably the regulator won't
like it either it's challenging the
position of the
other cash guarantee which is cash gold
of course is yet another
faith system uh why is that worth 31 000
pounds who says it's worth 31 000 pounds
well the answer is up against this
particular number let's make it 31 000
pounds
you've got hundreds of thousands of
people who are looking to buy at a price
just below that and people looking to
sell just above that
in other words you've got a huge weight
of argument on both sides of the bid on
the offer
to give it that price and a shift of
perception
politics will shift the numbers of
people and so the price is
confirmed or authenticated by the weight
of numbers of people trading it
i don't think governments will introduce
these things
you know as a general rule so the only
way i could see gold
really um re-emerging in the currency
system and it's
the cryptocurrencies are have been
fascinating for this
is is is through some form of
market driven reintroduction and that's
what the cryptocurrencies offer
right and they really do because that
because now we we don't need central
banks for currency clearing
internationally we don't need
um uh you know large
massive banking banking institutions in
order to
settle trades we don't we just don't
need that we can do it across the phone
these days we can do it through
cryptocurrencies
and i think you know there is a
much much much more efficient uh
currency waiting to happen that involves
yeah a cryptocurrency that sits on your
phone that you can trade with anyone in
the world
you know at zero
cost and the underlying um
the underlying sort of ledger based
entry
is gold sitting in a vault in somewhere
like singapore or somewhere like
switzerland or somewhere somewhere safe
where the government's not going to
steal it
and you know if you look at that the
whole monetary system based on
essentially gold in a vault
essentially like the gold exchange
standard
i could see that emerging and i you know
i'm very very very excited
by what um by what cryptocurrencies
offer not just the gold world but but
the whole
world economy as a result of this
because if you see
um the widespread adoption of a
gold-backed cryptocurrency that is
you know that people have confidence in
then you're going to see an awful lot of
change
i think it's it's it's a fantastic
development that we're seeing at the
moment
first of all because people are actually
discussing
what is money again they really care
about
those topics here they they they
research it they're they're they're
arguing they're
discussing it on twitter on facebook and
whatever i think that's that's that's
great yeah
there there should be competition of
currencies and i know that with all
those
icos now when i heard initial coin
offering for the first time i thought
it's a joke yeah it sounded like ipos in
back in the days and there's
95 of it is probably
probably probably rubbish here and they
won't be around in one or two years
but i think with bitcoin um
being created pretty similar to gold
because of the stock to flow
flow ratio with the inflation rate
that is just given um i think with
so much intervention in in in
in the whole space i'm meeting so many
brilliant
young people that only see opportunities
well if you go to a conference in the in
the finance industry people say okay
there's compliance and risk management
and there's new legislation
everything is just so much
administrational work and
when you talk to those young developers
in the crypto space they're only seeing
opportunities they're excited yeah
there's so much innovation going on and
i just love that
and i think that many many industries
especially the banking industry
they will get disrupted um and
and i think for for um
for for gold i don't regard it as
a competition because honestly i know
many people that that understand bitcoin
and they say
gold is totally fine yeah charlie morris
once said that
um bitcoin is electronic
gold something like that there's lots of
similarities
um so so i think basically a combination
of a cryptocurrency
uh and physical gold and there's lots of
projects at the moment yeah this will
probably be the future
and i i'm really looking forward to that
so
in in a world that is clearly moving
towards
frictionless payment uh
whether it's whether it's whether it's a
crypto
outcome or whether it's just the
blockchain solution to
all these cost problems delays etc and
payment
it does look very obvious to me that
we're heading to some form of unit that
everybody uses everywhere
so what i think can happen if we
if if people work it out properly and
this clearly is not going to be the
state's
preferred solution but you know gold
refers to its traditional role as the
money of the people
rather than paper being the money of the
state and the corporations
um and once its price is revealed in
other words once people remember
what gold is what its role it is what
it's always been
what it can be again then i think that
pure mass will become
uninteresting so i think that the
cryptos will become
basically i think they'll fold into a
gold and silver transmission on the
blockchain
thus far cryptocurrencies have yet to be
tested in the white heat of a financial
crisis
whereas gold is the one asset which has
survived every single panic in recorded
history
intact in 2008 gold's price fell
initially surprising many
but the reality was that gold was
providing liquidity
in an illiquid marketplace once market
stabilized and qe began in earnest
gold's price soared but how can we
expect gold to act
in the next financial crisis so i think
it's very i think it's very difficult
to speculate on what is going to happen
to gold and what's going to happen to um
to
how it's going to happen but i think
what is safe to say is that gold is
inversely correlated to confidence
in the financial system and the fact
that gold is independent
from the governments from the banking
system
is what crea and scarce is what creates
a tremendous potential
uh value i don't think we're going to
have another 2008.
i mean we're going to have something
that's different from 2008.
the reason i don't think necessarily
that's going to be the same is because
the problem that 2008 revealed which is
excessive debts
and excessive leverage has essentially
been kicked upstairs
on the to the sovereign level and so
what was a private
debt crisis is likely
will come back as a sovereign debt
crisis
which is a completely different animal
with very different
uh parameters so whereas a lot of people
are telling me now
i hear a lot of people saying well the
banking system is much safer
because the leverage is lower because
there's less rehabilitation
the answer that well that may be true
but if the currency in which they
measure everything
is debauched is debauched or devalued
and
that may happen overnight in a very
different way
that what happened in 2008 happened we
know the end game
we know that all of these debts cannot
be paid
we know that the unfunded liabilities
cannot be met
in in terms of real purchasing power so
then the question is
how does that gets resolved well there
are only a couple of ways it can get
resolved is either through inflation
or deflation deflation meaning defaults
in the likely event that we do have some
form of situations similar to that of
2008
and no matter what form that event might
take gold remains one of the few ways
that you can protect yourself
and preserve both your wealth and
purchasing power
man's connection to gold is not just a
financial one however
history is filled with deeply personal
stories that demonstrate gold's role
as a store of wealth as protection from
government confiscation via inflation
and debasement
and as an insurance policy that when
called upon
pays out in ways that change the lives
of those who own it
i know a person who grew up in vietnam
whose father was a translator for the us
military during vietnam war
and when the u.s left vietnam they were
unable to leave with the united with the
u.s forces
and so they were left behind and having
been left behind
they obviously were subjected to
oppression by the
communist regime it so happened that the
family of 14 one of the uncles there
was a dentist and he was able to
accumulate over the next whatever 10-12
years
a certain amount of gold so that in the
late 80s this family was able to pay
seven
ounces of gold per person so times 14
over 100 ounces of gold to get 14 seats
on a boat that left saigon in the middle
of the night
lost power and the next day drifted at
sea
for a few days and eventually was towed
to the malaysian coast by the malaysian
coast guard
they spent two years in a camp for
displaced persons
they eventually made their way to
singapore where the father was able to
go to the u.s embassy
present his credentials showed that he
was a translator for the us for
interpreter
for the u.s forces and the whole family
of 14 was given these
visas to come to the united states and
that's you know these people's lives
were saved uh and what did it do it's
you know what did it take it took seven
ounces of gold
per person for a family of 14. and so i
think that's as good
an example of gold being plan b
as i can come up with a couple years ago
i was at a wedding
and some friends of ours i was talking
with some friends of ours
and they were they were russian and
ukrainian and had emigrated here
uh we're now american citizens and we
got to talking
about what happened in the 1990s in
russia
they described to me the woman
my uh her father had been a doctor in
her village
in the ukraine and she said we'd had
enough
saved in the bank we were the richest
family in the village and we had enough
in the bank
to buy five cars which for her
apparently for that village was quite a
bit and she said they
they closed the banks for two weeks and
when they reopened the banks
we took the money out we bought
groceries for one month
and you know the uh her husband uh
said yeah similar story i was saving up
to buy a motorcycle and uh
had enough save to buy a motorcycle and
my dad wouldn't let me buy it
closed the banks for two weeks banks
opened back up i took the money out and
bought a carton of cigarettes
so i said to them i said so i probably
don't need to explain to you i said
how did gold do and they both laughed
and they said
anyone that had gold silver jewelry they
did they did totally fine
i love the story of how the french
spirited their gold
out of france and off to canada and
various other places
when the when the when the germans
arrived it's a great story
and they have to make a movie out of it
i mean it's really good
and basically what i mean they split up
their gold reserves into
into tiny little portions and they went
off on you know
mule carts and fishing boats and and
they they got their nation's wealth
out of the country and they did it
before the advancing army
i mean it was it's a it's a story of
daring do and all of that sort of stuff
fantastic
i once heard a story about
the soviet union um where gold obviously
was
was forbidden you could go to jail if
you had physical gold
but you were allowed to have wedding
rings
gold wedding rings and that was a smart
guy
and and he had like 50 wedding rings so
every month or every
couple of months he went to the market
and had just enormous purchasing power
due to his gold ring and i think this
clearly shows that
that you just have to own
at least some gold elemental
it may be but gold is also a complex and
confounding subject which has fostered
passionate debate
since the dawn of civilization hopefully
over the course of our journey
we've helped you understand a little
better why gold has been money to man
for thousands of years
the complexities that make it worth over
a thousand dollars an ounce
the way it's bought and sold around the
world and its place at the heart of the
modern day financial system
our aim hasn't been to persuade or
change minds but rather to explain how
this lump of yellow metal became the
object of so much fascination
and why it remains many thousands of
years after its discovery
the one universally accepted money
we hope we've shed some light on some of
the mysteries surrounding gold and
helped give you a better idea as to its
role in storing
and protecting wealth but when all said
and done whether you or i individually
believe gold to be money or not
is completely irrelevant gold has stood
the test of time
providing a stable store of wealth to
mankind for millennia
and as we look to an increasingly
uncertain future with fiat currencies
across the globe under siege from rising
debt levels
it remains the only money guaranteed to
[Music]
survive
[Music]
[Music]
you